I was looking somewhere in Isaiah and I
guess I came across the um question in
my mind what does it mean to be a slave
to Christ a slave to Christ you know
like how we're bought at a price and
stuff like that yes and I know we've
been we're made friends now with God you
know what I mean yeah but are we still
under that sure you are and the
scriptures say that we're slaves of
Christ here for example I want you to go
to James 1:1 new
Testament now the word Dulas is
variously translated as servant bonder
servant or slave but still it's the word
douas okay okay James 1:1 who is
James uh Jesus's brother no no read it
for me don't tell me just sorry uh James
a servant of God and of the Lord Jesus
Christ okay so that word is douas right
there now your transl translates it
servant other translations Bond servant
others would say slave so James is what
who's James a servant of God well finish
it and say it louder like you mean it
don't be intim like you're intim like
you're D I'm just scared of talking loud
because there's something about your
pres speak loud sister me okay okay a
servant of God and of the Lord Jesus
Christ to the 12 tribes which are
scattered abroad greeting okay now go to
Jude 1 1 now Jude is only one chapter of
25 25 verses go to Jude 1 you said Jude
1 yeah it's only one chapter of 25
verses so just read the first verse okay
Jude the servant of Jesus Christ and
brother of James to them that are
Sanctified by God the father and
preserved in Jesus Christ so notice you
are a servant douas variously translated
as Bond servant slave of Jesus Christ
and J James said of God and Jesus Christ
now let's go to Revelation 2 read verses
18 to
20 okay and unto the angel of the church
in
th yeah thyra yeah you're not gonna
visit it anytime soon so don't worry
about it okay um right these things said
the Son of God who has his eyes like
onto a flame of fire and his feet are
like Vine brass I Know Thy Works in
charity and service in faith and your
patience and your works and the last to
be more than the first not withstanding
I have a few things against thee because
you suffer sufferest that woman Jezebel
which call herself a prophetess to teach
and to seduce my servants my who my
servants so who's
speaking Jesus how do we know Jesus
because I want to make sure you're
paying attention to what you're reading
how do you know Jesus
oh the Son of God says the Son of God so
that's why it's important we understand
what we read that's why I wanted to know
how do you know from the context is
Jesus speaking says these are the words
of the Son of God right okay and the Son
of God says to the Christians at TH Tyra
there's a false prophetess Jezebel who
seduces my
servants my slaves my bonder servants
right so read Revelation 220 one more
time
not withstanding I have a few things
against thee because you sufferest that
woman Jezebel which calls herself a
prophetess to teach and seduce my
servants to commit fornication okay to
eat things yeah eat things sacrificed
titles so God Jesus in glory in heaven
says Believers on Earth are his servants
now what abot in the age to come in the
new Heavens new Earth where the Lord
Jesus transforms the Earth there'll be
no more evil no more sin No More Death
Revelation
22:3 okay read it from um and there
shall be no more curse in the Throne of
God and the lamb shall be in it and his
servants
shall sorry shall serve him wait so
after the Thousand Years After after the
new heaven Earth is ushered in believers
who are glorified and exalted will still
be the Servants of the trium god of the
father son holy
spirit all right now go to Luke 17 veres
to10
okay vers S Andrew that's not me peeping
that's her house someone's wondering
what's that noise peep that's I'm sorry
no it's okay it's the Peeper you got a
Peeping time all right Luke 17 7 to1 7
to 10 okay but which of you having a
servant plowing or feeding cattle will
say unto him by and by when he is come
from the field go and sit down to meet
and will not rather say unto him make
ready wherewith I may Su and G thyself
and serve me till I have eaten and
drunken and afterward you shall eat and
drink does he thank the servant because
he did the things that were commanded
him I shall not so likewise ye when you
shall have done all those things which
sister before you finish 10 Jesus is now
talking to the disciples and he says
likewise you the disciples you what
should your attitude do be when you do
what I command Now read it Luke
17:10 okay well which are commanded you
say we are unprofitable servants we have
done that which was our duty to do okay
so everyone gets it guys don't let abas
and the demons distract you because
you're letting them rob you of learning
the depth of scripture the meat of
scripture the beauty of scripture rebuke
that in Jesus name Jesus says to the
disciples one more time verse 10 so
likewise ye when you shall have done all
those things which are commanded you say
we are unprofitable servants we have
done that which was our duty to do okay
so sister Jesus says you my followers
when you do what I command your attitude
should be we are unprofitable servants
we did what was expected us to do
because you are our creator our owner
our Lord and we exist to serve you that
should be your
attitude okay okay all right so you see
the pattern right so it's not either or
it's not either I'm a servant or a
friend you are a servant you are a
friend and you are a son and you are a
brother and you are a queen or a king
when I say brother you know speak all
those things you're all of these things
because even a son can be a servant to
his father and even a brother can be a
servant to his brother in other words
the Bible says we're all of that we are
all of that as Christians I'm a servant
who obeys my master and desires his will
over above mine but I'm also a child of
God and I'm also a brother of Christ and
I'm also a king I'm all of that right
yeah Romans 616- 23 yes okay know you
not that to whom you yield yourself
servants to obey his servants you are to
whom you obey did you catch what a
servant is here's the definition a
servant is one who obeys his master and
makes his master's
will preeminent over his own right so
every one of us serve someone or
something all of us are servants to
someone or something that's what Paul
just said Paul just said do you not know
that whomever you obey you become the
slave of that thing or one that you obey
because that's what servitude is to obey
keep
going okay um continue yes keep going
okay whether of sin unto death or of
obedience unto righteousness but God be
thaned that you were the Servants of sin
but you have obeyed him from the heart
that form of Doctrine which was
delivered you being then made free from
sin you became the Servants of
righteousness I speak after the manner
of men because of the infirmity of your
flesh for as you have yielded your
members servants to uncleanliness and to
iniquity unto iniquity even so now yield
your members servants to righteousness
unto Holiness for when you were Servants
of sin you were free from righteousness
what fruit had you then in those things
whereof you are now ashamed for the end
of those things is death but now being
made free unto sin and become servants
to God you have your fruits so you are
what
now servants unto God so you are free
from slavery to sin you were a slave to
sin and you carried out sinful lust and
passions that were disgraceful to
mention you've been freed from slavery
to sin so that sin no longer owns you
and sin can no longer force you to do
that which is sinful and disgraceful
right right because now by the Holy
Spirit you've been made alive you're now
a slave to Christ and righteousness so
now offer your bodies in righteousness
doing that which is good so a servant is
one who serves by obeying his master's
will and carrying out his master's
desire so every Christian is a servant
because we're not simply children we're
not simply Brothers of Christ we are
servants commanded to carry out God's
Will and carry out his pleasures and
Delight in our lives because God's will
is what's best for us even though we may
not be aware of it for example take what
Paul said you used to offer your body
parts to that which is now disgraceful
and shameful in your sight you're now
ashamed of what you used to do right
isn't it true isn't it true that before
you were born of the spirit before you
were made alive in Christ you used to do
some shameful Wicked immoral things that
now that you're alive when you think
back it troubles you you're ashamed of
it and it disgusts you right yes why
what changed when you were doing it you
didn't have any shame what changed is
God Made You Alive by the spirit the
spirit is now changing your mind to
think God's thoughts after him and to
view things the way God views it so now
your world has changed your mindset has
changed you now look at things from
God's eyes and what God sees as
disgusting you now see but when you're a
slave to sin you delighted in sin and
saw nothing shameful about it right